y
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es muy cartel y
vértigo vice primer ministro de
kazajistán y ministro de asuntos
exteriores nos acompaña desde bruselas
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
gracias por recibirme su país fue
sacudido por la violencia a principios
de enero protestas pacíficas contra un
aumento en los precios del combustible
se convirtieron en disturbios violentos
las autoridades acusan a terroristas
extranjeros de estar detrás de estas
violencias y de haber ordenado una
represión si bien dichas autoridades han
recibido apoyo militar de rusia y de
antiguos países soviéticos después de
unos días de reportes contradictorios la
fiscalía general anunció una cifra
oficial de víctimas
225 muertos
sin embargo grupos de derechos humanos y
testigos en el terreno afirman que
murieron muchas más personas
mi pregunta es sencilla
procederá con absoluta transparencia
ante la comunidad internacional respecto
a lo que ocurrió en su país hace unos
días
y
esto sí por supuesto
como sabe nuestro presidente le ordenó a
todas las agencias de seguridad que
crearan un grupo de investigación
el cual llevara a cabo una investigación
a gran escala y sin duda cuando
recibamos las pruebas y las evidencias
de la implicación de terroristas en los
ataques contra los civiles y los
oficiales del gobierno y el personal de
seguridad las compartiremos con nuestros
colegas y con la comunidad internacional
estamos dispuestos a cooperar con las
ong internacionales las agencias de
derechos humanos de las naciones unidas
y la osce
ellos podrán acceder a posibles
testimonios o ustedes se los darán
ciudad
si cuando recibamos todos los resultados
de la investigación los compartiremos
como sabe yo estoy en bruselas vine a
europa para reunirme con nuestros
colegas aquí en bruselas
mañana en viena y luego en ginebra
y
el propósito de mi visita es compartir
información de primera mano y discutir
con mis colegas como podremos cooperar
juntos y cómo podemos hacer públicos los
resultados de nuestra investigación
y el presidente casi muerto acá él hizo
una declaración hace poco y habló de los
hitos 20.000 terroristas extranjeros
esto causa dudas porque no hay ninguna
evidencia respecto a esta inmensa cifra
20.000 terroristas extranjeros esto
parece ser una exageración no
y
en efecto los 20.000 terroristas son
sólo los que estaban en la ciudad de
almas
pero son incluso más si tenemos en
cuenta las otras 11 regiones que fueron
atacadas de manera simultánea
como ya lo mencioné compartiremos los
resultados de la investigación junto con
las pruebas de que estas personas
pertenecen a grupos terroristas
[Música]
pero usted mantiene que se trata de
terroristas extranjeros se mencionaron
terroristas islámicos pero según todos
los testigos en el terreno eso no fue el
caso no había terroristas extranjeros
tal vez había amotinadores pero esto
parece ser una manera para que
kazajistán obtenga apoyo internacional
agua nuestros ciudadanos compartieron
evidencias
entre esos militantes armados había
algunas personas que no podían hablar
kazajo o ruso
ahora
hablaban otros idiomas asiáticos
y algunos de los atacantes hablaban
kazajo con mucho acento
lo cual demuestra que no son hablantes
nativos
sino que aprendieron el kazajo
este tipo de prueba demuestra que hay
extranjeros entre los terroristas
donde está el ex presidente nursultán
nazarbáev no ha sido visto en público
desde el 28 de diciembre y se rumora que
se fue del país o que tal vez murió o
que puede estar en la cárcel donde están
y
francamente yo no sé en dónde está en
este momento pero su director de
comunicaciones dijo que está en
kazajistán
sé con seguridad que no ha muerto y que
tampoco está detenido o algo por el
estilo
no obstante vimos hace poco que el
presidente toca lo destituyó el 5 de
dinero de su cargo como jefe del consejo
de seguridad de kazajistán
y desde entonces el presidente ha
destituido a algunos aliados muy
cercanos al señor nazarbáev e incluso a
algunos miembros de su familia que
ocupaban cargos importantes como la
dirección de los servicios secretos o la
dirección de empresas de energías clave
pareciera que el nuevo régimen está
llevando a cabo una purga de algunos de
los aliados más cercanos al ex
presidente tal vez porque hay sospecha
de que habría jugado un papel en lo que
acaba de pasar en kazajistán que piensa
acerca de esto
y eso no está detrás
lo que puedo decir es que con la llegada
de nuestro presidente toca eps al cargo
de jefe del consejo de seguridad de
kazajistán se terminó el llamado periodo
de transición
como sabe la transferencia del poder
tomó cierto tiempo
mientras nuestro presidente toca epp se
convertía en el líder del partido en el
poder y de algunas instituciones
constitucionales como la asamblea del
pueblo de kazajistán
y finalmente asumió el cargo de jefe del
consejo de seguridad
si
adelante
pero el hecho de que algunos yernos que
tenían posiciones muy poderosas hayan
sido destituidos se debe a que el
presidente cree que su predecesor puede
haber jugado un papel en la violencia
que acaba de ocurrir
[Música]
como sabe el ex director del comité de
seguridad nacional el señor máximo
fue detenido junto con algunas otras
personas de este comité de seguridad
nacional pero estoy seguro de que
debemos esperar la investigación el
juicio y la decisión de la corte después
de esto podremos decir si estuvieron
involucrados o no en estos actos
violentos
claro pero entonces no lo descarta y el
hecho de que algunos yernos del
presidente que tenían cargos con mucho
poder económico estén siendo destituidos
es una señal de que el presidente cree
que hay un problema en la manera en que
el país ha sido dirigido y que tal vez
el señor nazarbáev su familia su círculo
cercano si jugaron un papel para tratar
de desestabilizarlo
usted se refiere al yerno el señor
kulibayev sí y a otros
y como sabe el señor kulibayev no
ocupaba ningún cargo oficial era el
director de la cámara de empresarios
kazajas llamada altamente
y el abandono de manera voluntaria ese
cargo ayer según se
y
claro pero esto no es accidental está de
acuerdo con que hay un impulso por parte
del presidente de tal vez limpiar un
poco algunas de las posiciones porque
las personas no estaban conformes
no creo que fuera presionado por nadie
pero puedo decir que durante su último
discurso en el parlamento
nuestro presidente le envió un mensaje
claro a las personas de kazajistán
debemos evitar toda desigualdad en la
riqueza así como las brechas salariales
entre los distintos sectores de la
población
tan bien última pregunta porque se nos
está acabando el tiempo
por primera vez hubo un llamado para que
una organización dominada por rusia
interviniera militarmente pidiendo que
las fuerzas se están retirando
pero esto nos sitúa a kasajistán bajo la
influencia de la rusia de vladimir putin
y que implica esto en cuanto a la
posibilidad de llevar a cabo una
política extranjera independiente
y para ser justos nuestras agencias de
seguridad no estaban listas para
enfrentar estos ataques terroristas
masivos
por esta razón nuestro presidente
decidió recurrir a cierta asistencia
internacional para combatirlos
el marco de la csc es la única base
legal para mantener tropas de paz
extranjeras en kazajistán
no tenemos ninguna otra organización ni
acuerdos bilaterales para recibir tropas
de paz en cada instante
por esta razón acudimos a la css sitio
así que recibimos a las fuerzas de
pacificación de los cinco estados
miembros
que son armenia belarús que están rusia
y tayikistán
como sabe la función de estas tropas de
paz estaba estrictamente limitada a
proveerle seguridad a la infraestructura
estratégica
lo cual nos permitió movilizar al
personal de las agencias de seguridad y
las fuerzas armadas para luchar contra
estos terroristas
y como sabe ellos completaron su misión
y se están retirando de kazajistán desde
el 13 de enero
esto toma alrededor de 10 días a causa
de la transferencia gradual de la
seguridad de estos lugares estratégicos
a nuestras agencias casas
agua
a casa
génesis
muchas gracias ministro muchas liberty
por concederle esta entrevista france24
y gracias a ustedes por acompañarnos
quédense con nosotros para más
información
[Música]